he'll reject I'm Greg
you are Selena Selena friend of Greg and
the real region yeah here today chelina
correct me if i'm wrong you are
currently in a relationship yes I am and
very much in love one of my favorite
channels is top five unknowns mm-hmm
they do these awesome list videos this
one is from last year February 15 2015
health five creepy Valentine's Day
Horror Story no irony pasta I just
wanted to you know make sure you were
familiar with Valentine's Day remind you
you're in love and remind you that
terrible things could happen
on the day of love okay all right yeah
love is exciting but you take it's pull
it produces such powerful emotions
enough to trigger your human to meet the
darkest I think that the gun can happen
even if the fact is potentially called a
personal to carry out dangerous
psychotic actions all in the name of
love the following are five IEP
Valentine's Day stories make sure to
stay for the last one oh great number
five I mean wedding night it is the best
moment of your life this is a short
story that happened in Stowe Vermont a
woman named Emily was left at her altar
or groom who never showed up
damn shame confused as to why he didn't
show up she left the church crying and
took a carriage which she arrived at the
bridge something scared her horse away
causing her life in the ensuing aha
some people have seen the ghost and say
that she looks very angry and many
believe that she's still hunting but it
would be gone before that way poor lady
that would be so bad there's a likely
saddest urban legends whenever like
someone is looking for like oh my child
or yeah I'll are looking for all of her
hi Donna so she had duck here and she
never found out what happened to her
ma'am maybe she did and she terrorized
him as a goat maybe he was just pulling
a prank
what maybe he was going to just like run
out from a tree into it yeah yeah yeah
exactly maybe that was the thing that
scared the horse that caused her so long
like I was in [ __ ] away and now she's
gone
you gotta be careful to prank people
yeah be responding on especially in
Vermont they are all frightened bunch
yeah and it's icy and cold over there
still macarons
is this a real story this is real okay
I'm ready probably expecting a romantic
story with the half not anymore here
yeah a couple decided to go to Paris
one wanted to end a relation what why
would he go to Paris and directly yeah
are you still with a dinner at the Alpha
power [ __ ] romantic right well it took
a turn for the worse we should decline
its proposal I wanted to end the call he
threatened to kill her if she had left
him a woman still declined the proposal
and with the shock of surprise the
madmen pushed her off the tower on this
very day some citizens of Paris report
citing the ghost of a young woman and
hearing screams from the tower and night
number three I think you should go to
Paris
yeah now is that Pilate the most
romantic place - god I just feel like
you know Paris to begin you should go to
the top of the Eiffel Tower
that's messed up stuff right there he
just pushed her off like a vagine' you
ruined Paris he ruined Paris for
everyone house hunting they ruin it
forever they ruined it for everyone
that's got to be the worst form of
rejection to propose I want to spend the
rest of my life in Mike remember so old
like am sadly I don't know for like a
long time as soon as you made that
decision like this one but the way the
story tells it like making her out to be
like aw it's kind of [ __ ] up like oh
you shouldn't need like Sue's if I just
want to leave him but look at this for a
second a little bit sure okay I Alice
all right guy killed her first
he clearly must have been some kind of
abuse of Apple that she was like I gotta
get out of this [ __ ] yeah maybe she was
like if I don't go to Paris he'll hurt
me
so I should go yeah that's her moment
was actually got challenged that moment
will you marry me I can't spend my life
with you you're dangerous
yeah exactly I think that if he had just
gone maybe got some therapy and like
some deep-rooted right that he had went
through in his life
maybe she'd want to do more or she
deserved it
okay come on number three I never they
remember here in love right now loving
someone who loved another can be
difficult to know are you setting takes
place in castelló this on Michael a
fortress building a 1600 a young
beautiful Spanish hour means always is
forced into an arranged marriage she was
to be the young wife of the fortress
commander priority she wasn't too fond
of them he didn't pay any attention to
her and high dry humor ha
we found a furloughed assistant captain
Manuel Bella to be more appealing to
repeat it looks like a crime tolerance
with something she come and spend the
night away dollars had a strong perfume
aroma now Robin captain Abela of which
the colonel began to notice suddenly
dollar s and the captain went missing
the colonel made up a story about the
disappearance by telling soldiers at
French that dollar is moved back to her
hometown in Spain and that the captain
was reassigned to Cuba after 50 years
the truth came out about their son
disappearance when the Americans took
over the fortress a soldier has
discovered that one of the dungeons
bricked were out of place upon a removal
of the brick a hidden rules revealed
inside the hidden room their actions
that were found and remains up to
skeletal bodies chainsaw or even today
people had reported a touch of cold spot
the smell of strong perfume and saline
or number two um he chained them and let
them starve to death
I always see did it so they could be
getting we see died together they look
really happy wait there at me used to
while there were skills
she was cheating on well she didn't love
him because he didn't even painted
anymore
and what she didn't like his dry humor
well that is another thing yeah
ratted yeah confused well no he just
didn't seem like the right guy for her
and other guys maybe was that literally
off looks
she's clearly a shallow human station
well they were meant to be together and
they died honestly if I loved a woman
yeah and she I found out she was having
an affair with another man probably
wouldn't kill her I might be tempted to
kill him yeah I could see that yeah
I would probably do that a brilliant
idea fine like off like the engine like
like something where you can just put a
wall up so they can hear them on the
other side but they're changing they
start after destiny yes something like
that enough great just thank god there's
no basement
okay let's do this or glass door they
don't get as bad as thank you Cooper I
got 300 was an American shop owner let
just means to San Agustin Florida he
barely knew anybody in town but worked
very hard long hours for himself one
night he took a break and decided to
take a walk along the seawall now that
face bog randomly appeared making it
difficult for himself to see but his
ears could sense the sound of a woman
singing the singing sound seems to be
approaching him closer and closer until
a beautiful woman suddenly appeared to
his eyes the shop owner was startled by
her beauty and after she was okay she
stopped singing and slowly looked at him
I replied I am lost I'm trying to plan
my way home the shop owner offered his
help as she kept refusing her face
expression quickly switched to a silent
smile she walked away and disappeared
into the midst of the fog the next night
the shop owner walked in the same time
but he didn't find her he repeated the
same rhythm every night hoping to see
the woman again but there was no sign of
her until one night the same fog dropped
again the same woman reappeared they
spoke the night away during a
conversation the woman told them that
she found her way home the shop owner
insisted on coming with her she replied
by saying to come meet her tomorrow
night he agreed to meet her and the fog
had lifted that day was the last day
that the shop owner was seen today it is
said that whenever it takes father
appears in town a low pitch thing
singing to be heard across the sea at
San Agustin number one yes you know like
you never know sometimes you might fall
in love with a ghost you have to be
caramel do you see all mobile because
you never know you gotta be careful they
could be emotionally damaging to you it
could have some type of SPD or it could
be dead or it could be hindering someone
and think
they're beautiful and like woman of your
dreams and then you meet up with her and
she's a go she's a ghost
she's dead she's gone she can't have
your being here yeah exactly
huh and then you'll disappear to candy
key Carol no no I heard that yeah I mean
I do hear that that's our very
insightful commentary haha ridiculous or
for a man to like fall in love having
time like you fell in love with her
why'd she have to be well we don't know
like she might have taken him away too
late this magical place we don't know
yeah or she couldn't took a soul fatal
program or that what their story is
about a boy was deeply in love with a
girl image clause in this case when I'm
in there Boy George a little section for
her was so deep that he would do
anything for her he admired her beauty
but with this King jealousy to
understand describes her as a girl with
every guy which was hard one day the
girl of his dream was getting yelled at
and pushed against the brick wall at
school by boiling James James was the
type of person that would easily get
angry and could definitely not be taken
lightly
even though it's hard burned in anger
all George could do was stand there and
watch damn after the painful event had
occurred
George would watch her walking home by
herself whom James and his girlfriend
Taylor would follow insulting and all
that anger George even more but still he
couldn't physically do anything against
Jean instead she found a way to make it
up for her by speaking with Ben cool he
made his way to the fish store oh no I
hate fish
his mother worked night shift at a local
bar and his father was never home this
made it perfect for him to speak out of
the house Curley managed to get inside
James house and snuck into his room
while he was asleep a big snored change
was made his mouth voluble for any now
hopefully dropped five of the thirty
fish hooks yet
purchase into James mouth he began
coughing has the hooks case against the
walls of his growth
he added ten more to the five it pierced
through James neck and the inside
James attempted to scream but he
couldn't and began to choke from the
same blood
George was continuously as cooks at the
hooks and finally pulled out the last
and post and drop it into George's mouth
he attempted to scream one last time but
garbled noises is all about him now
finally James - I'm choking on his own
blood I can watch a country corner the
next day James returned to school only
to see Taylor doing rocks like a poor
girl
that's when he knew that Taylor would
become his night cream later that day
George walked to a local late
he brought a bucket open and filled it
with over 80 reaches and create there
was collapse if you watch her write them
outside her house as pure walk towards
the phone he made his way inside of her
house and went to the bathroom where she
had a bubble doctor waiting here what hi
little girls act evocative Lisa and
dumped it into a bubble bath and left
about them tied to another ring when she
came back she unknowingly plungers off
into the bathtub minutes have passed
George slowly walked back into the
bathroom only to see that Taylor's eyes
glazed with that and skin pale from
blood loss let's say that you're
attached to a special someone would you
do anything beyond the norm to keep that
person happy come on Sega
Cargill hey whoever George's I think he
liked the fish okay think he likes this
get his prey the hooks the leeches I
love you fresh worms when you clean fish
yeah I get it
you I am I get where you're going we're
all that driving everyone right I think
no again I thought this would be kind of
a cool movie yeah like a high schooler
boy who's like in love with the girl
that he knows he's not physically strong
enough to go yeah he just gets back in
like what is he can it's a sick
disgusting lies I think yeah like he was
very creative about that oh just
imagining that oh yeah
although if I did go in
like I'll probably figure out there was
wages in their league pretty seriously I
am I would be ascared head yes because
he was so terrified though but I would
be out of that immediately I mean he
just loved this girl I wonder if thought
he ended up with her why they get the
other high what happening would you have
stated in let's say a couple all right
lastly your self in this scenario okay a
couple is taunting you constantly
physically hurting you yes throwing
rocks at you yeah bullying the [ __ ] I
was bullied and I did get rocks on I
mean did your file yes engine what if a
boy mm-hmm named Jorge yeah Mexican kid
only Mexican kid and kinetic allergic up
up and let's say hmm he found out who
killed those people for you to protect
you and you know he wanted was to take
you out from the city I wouldn't be
terrified of it really
I took care I would think that's
romantic
George is a man I agree well how do we
have done peace in the lesson he around
a little bit him out it was old like a
frat go pull the prints old talk to the
girl and told her like some ways that
she could get help like maybe here's
some fish I stand up to that no I stood
up to the bullies
you're not nice Oh sobbing already it
shaped me to be the person when I am
today I just think that be a great like
medical movie you know yeah as I said
she's bullying is a real thing bullying
obsessing they're shooting a documentary
bully no I I do thank you talk and feel
bad like I'm terrified for him children
of today we need more George's yeah you
can't solve bullying by bullying back
that's why he's got lemonade them so
Oh subscribe it's off I've unknown I'm
Greg
welcome to the real rejects totally all
movie god yeah yeah chelina hi scott
chelina is on instagram and snapchat at
light coach chill all horror themed
topics so it's all positive it'll love
she's a very kind hearted person and I
feel bad because he hasn't been on this
channel many many many months
can you saved these by Jamie uh yeah
yeah exactly
baby scenario food was only one man take
character America what should take care
of Trump's America
you voted Trump right how can you
totally do my the kind of person who was
aware then solely to plan somewhere else
I find that political discussions on the
internet tend to be the most mature your
and your videos that I in my video it's
the most mature and people are listen to
each other on the internet no one
attacks I find it to be a very zen
environment when you bring up politics